a cough a fever an aching body for the
past week nazaneen-e a gory Ratcliffe
has been sick
she says the officials that the Iranian
prison where she's jailed won't test her
for coronavirus even though there have
been reports that one inmate has died of
the disease her family back in the UK
want the government to intervene I want
them to be on the phone every day if I'm
honest just you know calling and saying
what can we be sent the test results can
be sent the test results can we be said
like keeping it that simple and that
clear Richard Ratcliffe says the
prison's already substandard medical
care has been stretched to breaking
point because of the way corona virus
has spread throughout Iran last week the
prison ran out of all cleaning materials
so they ran out of a bleach they ran out
of detergent they ran out of sanitarium
jail for your hands and they run out of
any medicine apart from aspirin and
they're in the prison clinic and in that
context it's terrifying
covert 19 has killed at least 50 people
in Iran
it's the highest number of deaths
outside China the country's vice
president and deputy health minister
have been infected on Sunday the UK
evacuated all non-essential embassy
staff observers believe the number of
cases of Cobra 19 have been
underreported the problem is they they
don't you know close that the cities
that don't go to guarantee so it's
easier to spread the virus everywhere
and the problem again is it's in the
kind of heart of Middle East it's not
Iran we've got pilgrims from other
countries coming to Iran and they go to
other countries
on Saturday the u.s. banned travel from
Iran as governments across the world
strengthened their responses Italy
closed churches and postponed football
matches as they announced that 34 people
had now died from covert 19 with a total
of almost 1,700 cases in France the
world famous Louvre gallery closed staff
said they were too scared to come to
work South Korea shut churches in
affected area
and in Japan the Tokyo Marathon was
restricted to elite athletes only not
that many people turned out to watch
anyway and whilst for many the idea of
being diagnosed is frightening
the Ratcliffe family say they just want
to know so that Nazanin can get the
right treatment if she has the disease
Katarina Vuitton see Sky News